folks joe derosa from the taste buds pod
here your favorite taste buddy let's be
honest anyway i got a bunch of shows
coming up across the country starting in
july
in san francisco
uh
i gotta take it again
folks this is joe derose here from the
taste buds pod
your favorite taste buddy let's be
honest anyway i got a bunch of shows
coming up starting in july starting in
fairfield connecticut then i'm on to san
francisco then on to los angeles
california in august i'll be in atlantic
city new jersey uh september i'm going
out to san diego uh i gotta run through
michigan in november i believe uh and
then some other stuff sprinkled in
between there anyway go to
joederosainfo.com
for all information on shows and tickets
you can buy them right there through the
site also joey roses my sandwich shop
and social club and bar in the lower
east side of new york city open six days
a week tuesday through sunday hit
joeyrosesnyc.com
for details
what's up taste buddies i have six
cities in july starting july 15th we're
doing vegas phoenix and boulder colorado
15 16 17. and then 20 21 and 22 we're in
portland seattle and vancouver uh my
first time in vegas i'll be at the new
virgin hotel that's going to be exciting
they're all on sale right now and that
will be it until october a bunch of new
dates for october through december
they're all on the website as well right
now but i'm finally hitting canada a
bunch richmond virginia hershey pa
knoxville atlanta birmingham
jacksonville tampa orlando sacramento
san jose and santa rosa all those to
close out the year all on sale right now
at savolcanocomedy.com
i hope to see you guys
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right taste buds man
yeah they're coming to the mic i'm
talking taste buds
welcome to t-a-s-t-e
it's a beautiful day today and we're in
good mood good morning it's beautiful
who sings it
it's the song in kingpin that's all i
know oh come on that song has been
around since the 60s maybe johnny mathis
i think it's called i think it's the
rascals the rascals go to the video tape
pimp
listen we're in
good
something happened
venus is mercury's in retrograde you and
i are in a good mood at the same exact
time i would say did you have a pep in
your step today i got a pepper
maybe it's because i haven't seen pimp
in a while either maybe he brought me
life as the kids call it yesterday i was
not in a great mood
no
don't take shots
no this is playful now you don't need to
take shots there's no shots but joe when
shots are fired
you'll know they're flying please listen
so you so yesterday
so i was very sick for a week i think i
had covered
the rapids were saying negative
but then i read that omnicron doesn't
turn up on rapids
and
by the time i was feeling good enough to
go get a pcr my fever was gone and stuff
and my doctor was like look dude you've
already quarantined like just do the
quarantine
you don't know if you had it
no but he was like look fluffy rascals
it is the rascals he goes but flu
season's done he goes you're probably a
[ __ ] covet man yeah and then i
started reading that on the crown
doesn't show up on the pcr tests either
so i was just like no that can't be
right otherwise the last year would have
been like nobody would have had covet
there's articles saying it
really yes i noticed we're both giving
them the legs today
yeah so oh by the way look
the shorts are back yeah
and you're gonna be in trouble hey now
hey now josh are back
[Laughter]
i bought a pair of new uh nike um
uh like basketball shorts stand up
stand up stand up get up stand up
nike
basketball shorts usher uh yeah sure
yeah no that's bob marley i know you
come on joe with me today
but listen
listen we're giving them we're giving
them the milky white legs today rapids
may not detect omnicron
i think it's omicron and i'm just going
to oh my god for you i mean say omnicon
you can continue save for my sake yeah
but also too then i started reading
things that said on the pcr it won't
show up with omicron until after you've
had it's that [ __ ] we've all had enough
it's batshit so anyway my doctor goes
just do the quarantine and i go all
right i'll just so i did and you did it
i did a strict quarantine
um i was very careful you did a strict
team
i'm telling you i saw nobody okay i had
food i had food delivered left outside
my door okay i didn't see one person
contactless for five by the way
i did a real quarantine five whole days
after my fever was gone
so i didn't even do it from you were in
the house that long yes
luckily you have the terrorists
i didn't even go on the terrorists get
out of it you weren't stir crazy babe
you think i didn't love
five straight days of laying in my like
well i probably have it yeah so uh
everybody clear i'm not gonna be around
yes five straight days i'm late in my
bed i eat
fast food delivery oh i know and you
weren't you didn't have symptoms
uh
no i mean my fever was gone i picked you
walking around the house my fever was
gone i didn't feel good but my fever was
gone
yeah i had it too my second my second
one was yeah yeah i picked you this way
i picked you i picked you in the house
tidy whites
close ac crank just walking around like
going like that like walking past your
like your shelves of dvds like just
going like that and be like what am i
gonna watch
but are you giving me too much credit i
didn't even make it to the living room
no
went come on joe except for the la the
last two days is when i finally went in
the living room i did full-on
bed
ipad on lap with the with the ipad
pillow
food getting delivered eating big macs
in my bed watching whatever i wanted
playing my switch it was
heavenly
i in in a dose i get that but like four
or five days of not coming out of the
bedroom i did three and a half of that
and then i did a day and a half in the
living room where i sat down you need to
stretch your gams i mean i got up and
went right but you didn't you didn't
congregate in the living room
you didn't like what are you doing you
cranking ac still you got the window
open with debris coming in i didn't i
just had the fan on yeah because it
wasn't that hot yet what am i saying
yeah but then then i got hit with the
post covet exhaustion for a week you
were exhausted from yeah so that no all
last week i was telling pamper earlier
today i go i go up until like this past
saturday zero stem
dude i went and did two sets at the
cellar on saturday and i was like i
gotta go home i have nothing in me
winded and like i know i know i'm off
when i think when i get invited to go
have drinks and i'm like i don't want to
yeah that's not you that's not me at all
and that's kobe joe that's kova joe
joe so
so the post damn is just jovid
jovid
with these
teen
jovid don't say wine teen that sounds
too close to weinstein no wine like i
whine
jovid
wine teen i whine
you whine like you complain yeah but
that's that's not jovid is replaceable
with covert and jova not quarantine and
weintino oh covet 19. jovid weinstein
coveted 19. forgot all about it i think
he's talking about quarantine i forgot
about the 19. yeah because it's covered
22. i mean it's you know covered wine
team no jovid weintz
covert 19 the 19 was because of the year
i thought it was i could be wrong
i thought it was because yeah but you
know what you're probably right because
then why haven't we heard of covert 20
cover 21 cover 22 and so forth and so on
and so forth
and so on no yeah it is 19.
oh well i guess it's like where it
originated it's like the origin story
yeah i don't think you update it with
the year
yeah but the new the new uh what do you
call those variations this is a very
variant of that strain okay
but
but
so so
yesterday
was the first day i felt like sort of
normal again i still don't feel like
drinking but like i felt like like i got
up i went i did a ton of stuff for the
bar like i was
i was moving and then today i was like
got up i was in a great mood i was happy
to be seeing you guys
i was looking forward to the drive
you know what sometimes i love a nice
drive yeah i don't care as long as
they're not in traffic i love you put
the windows down turn that radio up get
the breeze going through your curly
locks yeah exactly exactly let me ask
you a question when was the last time
you drove because i don't you're in an
apartment building
and i've never lived on like even in my
last x amount i've never lived like
stand alone nobody can hear me so i
always daydream about turning this radio
up as loud as it'll possibly go you
really let out [ __ ] when you do that
like it's like going to see live music
and just going nuts which i haven't done
and i anytime i can get them ready up to
a little bit of a decibel level it
really energizes me so i couldn't do it
in the house really like i wanted so one
day i went out i went for a drive and i
turned the radio up to max volume in the
car
and just drove on the expressway
scream singing my lungs out and it would
it felt
like a like a workout it felt i was it
was so much so let me ask you a question
when was the last time you just sang out
loud and turned your car radio all the
way up like that
i do it weekly you turn your radio all
the way up i don't even
like the guy in office space
yeah yes i go all in
the uh but but
yesterday i was in a great mood what's
that song
it's scarface the hand of the dead body
that he's rapping at the beginning yeah
but there's another ghetto boys one
where he's looking traffic he's
interested you know that the one hand of
the dead body is the one when he's in
traffic steel is the one they play when
they kill the uh copy machine yeah yeah
that's that's one of my favorite parts
when the indian guy goes back up in your
ass with the resurrection yeah no but
there's a there's another ghetto boys
one you're not mentioning they play damn
it feels good to be a gangster when
they're passing through this i thought
it was the other one
okay not that one i thought it was
another one not damn if it existed
oh yeah you're right that's right of
course famously yeah those are yeah not
my mind's playing tricks on me right
right okay um
i was in a great mood yesterday
until i talked to
the drag of all drags ari shafir
[Music]
i mean it's just let's go right there
but you were in a fear of a black planet
shirt yes i was uh in montauk last year
bogart the story no but i didn't want to
forget it what the hell is that my adhd
won't let me come back to that so all
right go ahead uh bookmark it you got it
no go ahead that's still going no no go
ahead i saw chuck d when i was eating
breakfast in a small little cafe yeah
that's so weird straight up it was like
there was like five people in the place
he got him but i was like that's [ __ ]
that's chuck t that's right and he
walked out i almost like went out and
was like hey
you should have but yeah i met cool
keith from ultramagnetic season catches
deadly once
wow that was pretty cool uh chuck t if
you're watching and we know that you are
please reach out we'd love to have you
as a guest on the podcast argue with
some foods yeah argue about social
issues with you gotta argue and really
get on your side about the social media
keith if you're watching we'd love to
have you too anybody anybody if you're
watching anybody
famous rappers well anybody classic
rappers keith murrow come on
what you know keith murray i don't know
him but i met him and he he liked the
show
and i was like you're keith murray and
he's like oh dude he jokers you mean he
likes
yes sorry i damn it
that's a real buzzkill when you do that
i didn't mean to do that at all i'm just
thinking how large you did that the
other week with cindy lauper
i said yeah you thought you liked the
show right now um please sorry
the drag of all drags are you going to
the game tomorrow what is the matter
with you but are you no i can't go oh
are you going yeah i took off like two
months ago for it
i can't go because i got to do a
recording session
i know i know it'll be a fun little
thing yeah i know i'm missing out on the
whole thing anyway whatever why'd you
say what's wrong with me you thought i
was changing the subject again yeah i
wasn't all right
this kid
me no ari
[Laughter]
today he's like who's on first everybody
thinks ari's just fun-loving
[Laughter]
easy going
you've never met a buzzkill like this
guy in your life i told him the other
week i was going to get a cat
and i was like all like excited i go
dude i've thought about it for literally
i remember this two years it's off the
table i finally have decided i'm gonna
do it i figured out how i'm gonna do it
i got rid of
one of my chairs in my living room so i
had room for like a proper setup for the
cat and all that stuff because you know
i don't have a huge apartment
i'm all excited dude i can't wait i know
people that have cats to adopt there's a
cat place across the street from me they
approved me everything's lining up for
you everything's lined up he goes
yeah i mean if you want your apartment
to smell
i'm like
it won't smell and he's like yes it will
your apartment will definitely smell and
i go i love that your art your pressure
you put you tuck your hand here
[ __ ] your arm that he does that with you
yeah i go i won't
i go there's there's like ways around
that now you can get around he goes oh
yeah oh yeah because you're the one
whose house won't smell from a cat okay
just kills it just kills it i told him
that i go i go what are you doing
tomorrow he goes
i'm busy why i go i gotta drive to the
poconos i'm starting to look at houses
out in the poconos i think i might want
to buy a house out there he goes
that's [ __ ] crazy
what is
wrong with you
well well
with the house
yeah again he's not really like getting
behind your what you're doing
but is he maybe trying to give you
advice as a friend no he's a psycho
who doesn't know how to filter his
thoughts
and says terrible [ __ ] to you that kills
your dreams right uh now i'm not gonna
get into what was going on yesterday but
i was on a text uh with ari yesterday
it was the one i was yeah yeah
and i made fun of a comedy related thing
and ari will do this
ari will get a bug up his ass
he did this to me last halloween i saw
listen i'm not taking any i see
there's good people on both sides i see
i see what was going on but i i actually
didn't
i didn't necessarily disagree with him
but i also didn't necessarily disagree
with you
oh you middle of the road no
but no but you know that
i speak truth i told you i can't just
just do it to do it if i don't really
feel i'm just gonna let it be known but
i could also appreciate it i was
throwing something out to a couple
friends
that was
a
you made me laugh it was a bashable
in light-hearted
like guys let's just make sure i don't
know you know there's one person who who
didn't join in well let's not talk about
it all right we want we want one but but
that person definitely played the fifth
but i but i can can i say though that i
really
saw there i was saying side texts i i
really that was said oh really
oh yeah who's on the side who who went
in the breakout room i'm not i'm not
gonna give away names
a lot was said inside texts
well i know i know at least was it the
scientific seeing one other person or
more than one i'm not gonna say you side
texted i'm not gonna say i know you i
know what you did you side texted with
two other people
you don't know what i did and you're
wrong
with more than two
i know who used the one side text was
with but i'm telling you
this was a completely
stupid let's just trash
yeah
and ari he gets a bug up his ass or he
just goes i'm just not gonna go along
with this
and he just wouldn't and then ari does a
thing too on on any group text
with me on it where he will single me
out and go after me particularly hard he
did it last halloween with the costumes
when i let slide that we were going to
dress up as dinosaurs by accident
he do you remember that night we were
hanging out in your apartment i know
we were going to dress up as dinosaurs
remember we were going to draw oh yeah
i let it slip by accident and then there
was that night we were all hanging out
at the apartment
it was you me
um uh ryan mcginley came over a bunch of
us were hanging out i think embergio
came over we were all hanging out
and we were all drinking having a great
time and but we were also texting about
halloween okay
and ari
like
focused in on me
that i had ruined halloween because i
let the costume slip and he would not
let it go and he just kept on kept on to
the point where i had to pull aside
several people during the hang and be
like am i crazy
look at this and people were like i
think he just knows he's getting he's
just busting your chops
so easy but i rattled him up yesterday i
finally got him to crack yeah because i
kept being so sarcastic and being like
i'm so sorry ari that i want to trash
something let's all be positive and i
kept saying the positive text and then
he finally was like you can keep pushing
this if you want
but nobody's on your
i side by it
i stand by my standby my initial text i
get my own i get both i get both
comments i get both sides
i mean the kids i can see what you mean
but i also kind of feel the way that he
thinks too
his defenses were so bad
and he did the he did the thing i hate
where i kept saying yeah but what about
this and he kept answering a question i
wasn't asking and that was like his
defense
he it was just bad defenses it was just
bad defense i wonder how because people
don't have context yeah i'm wondering
over here is this like a confrontation
that was broken down later or is it
material that's being broken i'm going
to say it right now no no no don't say
anything
i don't want any part of that
no no you don't reveal stuff like that
all right there's not even a general
what were you going to do what were you
going to reveal
just say what i said not the top of that
conversation
i actually don't think i said anything
bad you didn't but
i don't i i operate on i operate on
but you didn't agree with me though i
didn't so there you go but nobody needs
to understand even the like
nobody needs to even be in the
neighborhood
all right i'll give a i'll give an
analog an analogous
and then
is that a word yeah
okay so analogous really you think this
kid's gonna spill this right no look at
him going
i'll give you 20 tries to spell
analogous
[Laughter]
today is something's happening today
he he spells analogous on the first try
he can't spell the on the first try
anal oh gauss that was wild wait did you
start to do it in the pre-populated the
rest yeah of course okay
so you got an assist
let's just say okay but i don't know i
don't know if you're capable of giving a
proper analogous listen we're not on the
we're not live pimp can cut it out if i
oh
huh why even play with fire but okay go
ahead it's not even bad but you were
making fun of let's say you were making
fun of who's making fun of what let's
say you i'm just this is my analogy okay
let's say you were making fun of the
filet of fish okay
and that was your whole thing man the
filet of fish mcdonald's i never
realized i was doing it oh we know
and your whole thing was the [ __ ] by the
way it sucks
mcdonald's gonna chip in and send you
something i know let's go
he's mentioned you for two years by the
way one of the fans said why isn't joey
rose is a franchisee of mcdonald's oh it
should be we could be their new chipotle
you know what you could do i don't know
how you would do this i don't know how
you would do it but you should serve
mcdonald's fries
i wonder if we could cross pro some of
those big box stores on the lower east
side where we are will do a cross
promotion with independent stuff because
they want to be accepted in the
neighborhood i wonder how you get the
lower east side mcdonald's to come in on
a cross promotion oh my god
you should throw up a party one time
when mcdonald's have the [ __ ]
characters there and everything
come on joe stick with me and i will
give you all the ideas hold on maybe for
my birthday this year
wait it's baked it's your birthday
hosted by ronald mcdonald should we have
a grown-up mcdonald's party for my
birthday 100
100
100
we'll get all the characters there we'll
have them cater it
oh my god it'll be great it'll be great
there'll be prizes we can hand out
coupons for sundays happy meals yeah
wow all the top comedians in a ball pit
um how hard do you think it is to get
the characters to go out i mean you just
remember
could you could you portion off part of
the rv and make it a ball pit
amazing
holy [ __ ]
i don't know
i could do something it's fun
put a pimp can you please make a note of
that so we do not forget that idea
because we will forget it i mean it's a
pretty broad big idea i don't know if
we're gonna forget it um
wait were we just talking about better
help better help better help better help
better help better help better help
wow that's a jingle you just made up yes
right there
let's talk about ways to take care of
our own minds sally babe do you do it
well do you take care of your mind as
well as you take care of your car
because if you don't i'd like to now
bring you a word from our sponsor
better help
uh
your mind is important your brain is
important and you should be tending to
it as much as you tend to all the other
things in your life be it devices or
or activities or whatever it is there
are plenty of ways to support a healthy
brain
uh and let's talk about them you could
learn a little language you could take
power naps
but hey then there's better help online
therapy how we care for our mind affects
how we experience our lives why not take
the time to invest in your own
mental health okay
uh i like better help a lot
i like that they are making therapy
accessible
uh i think that's a very important thing
i think therapy is not as accessible as
it should be
it's not just accessible though it's
also very convenient on top of being
accessible yes because there's another
big part of it you know it's you can
reach therapists
uh all over the country
you can be speaking to someone within a
couple of days
um you can you don't have to turn your
camera on if you don't want to be seen i
find a lot of people that
uh have not been to therapy yet have
questions about it and some of the
things that they say are like i don't
know who to choose i don't know where to
go i don't really want to see people to
see me like
there's a stigma behind it that i'd like
for it to be taken away and i think but
if you're one of those people that want
to dip a toe like you always say you
don't even have to leave your house you
don't have to turn on the camera and you
can still just start talking to somebody
i agree i agree you can be matched with
a therapist too through better help in
under 48 hours that's incredible uh and
our listeners get 10 off the first month
at betterhelp.com taste buds
excuse me sorry he just had a sandwich
he had a salad he had a salad with eddie
i just saw him eat a
full hard-boiled egg in one bite uh
better help is also more affordable than
person therapy yeah so anyway ten
percent off to our listeners for the
first month at betterhelp.com tastebuds
that's betterhelp.com
tastebuds
let's talk about noon
i'm here say whale whale
noom
all right folks i like doom i like what
they're
doing is the chief rocket keep it going
uh i like knew my video you're talking
about them yeah i've used newm in fact
uh i've gotten some great recipes from
noob you talked about i'm not joking
two minutes ago yes it came out yeah i
didn't realize they were on today's uh
episode so that's that that was
unprompted but i i like newm quite a bit
um they're a psychology-based approach
to losing weight
i think
it's a very very helpful approach for a
guy like me for a guy like sal uh
where people that
tend to emotionally eat and that doesn't
always mean sad that doesn't always mean
i'm depressed so i'm gonna go eat a cake
or something like that right sometimes
it just means
you get ex you're excited about the
evening and you equate that to eating a
bunch of stuff that isn't great for you
you're excited to go to the movies and
you equate that to now i need to eat a
bunch of candy and butter covered
popcorn
uh you're excited to go to the beach and
that means you've got to eat
tons of uh uh uh you know hot dogs or
whatever noon breaks all that down right
it gives you practical knowledge it
helps you build a more sustainable like
it helps you build better long-term
habits and behaviors for the way that
you eat yes right yeah it's uh
scientifically proven principles like
cognitive behavioral therapy which is
great therapy i've actually done that in
my past and it helps people better
understand their relationship with food
why they eat what they do
uh and it's a weight loss job so that's
the one thing that that i think that uh
we're responding to new before at least
i know is that like it is
it's it's a given that we're going to
fluctuate and wait over time i've
fluctuated like my whole life up and
down 50 pounds my whole life at any
given moment i'm on that scale and we're
not striving for perfection it's a
journey this is what they say so you
don't beat yourself up over something
because it's not restrictive dieting or
anything like that it's just more of a
changing of the way that you
your relationship with food it's a
journey weight loss is a journey they
understand the journey is difficult and
that's why they take this very unique
very effective approach more than 60
percent of users lose 5 or more
body weight by 16 weeks in and more than
60 percent of users engaged with the
program keep that weight off for at
least a year
noom is grounded in science let's yeah
let's let's let's scroll down a little
bit which is great yeah
and i think that's important you know
science is a big is a big factor in all
this one thing i liked it's like these
little tips that you learn like
why water-based
or or water
heavier water foods
are better to snack on like for instance
like they talk about like raisins versus
grapes and they're like if you want a
snack eat grapes
why because grapes are whatever
percentage water and you will fill up a
lot faster and therefore ingest
less calories less whatever right
whereas raisins nothing wrong with
raisins if they're natural raisins but
they're tiny and they contain no water
so you're gonna eat a lot more of them
to get full you fall off track to get
you right back on again it's about
progress not perfection uh they empower
you and it is all flexible it shouldn't
be stressful start building better
habits for healthier long-term results
sign up for your trial at
noom.com taste bud that's n o o m dot
com slash taste bud that's start
building better habits for healthier
long term results
sign up for your trial at noom.com taste
bud
taste bud
wait were we just talking about
mcdonald's in your birthday
oh my analogy
my analogy no no my analogy
fillet of fish by the way
yeah play fish only mcdonald's item i've
never eaten
only never even took a bite never not
curious no i i it's not my style
i want no parts of it
i feel like i've never ordered it but i
feel like i've chewed it even as a kid i
hated fish sticks fish patties
yeah you know fish sticks that came
around on because they're really not
like they taste like fried anything
you would think i wouldn't like it i was
a finicky eater but
at this age if i was really like
starving and like there was fish sticks
and cocktail sauce or tartar sauce i'd
eat it i don't remember the last time i
came across the fish stick in the wild
are you i've never i don't i've never
come across one in the wild i know i've
always been
or delusion that they were healthy for
you at one point yeah fried fake fish
how marketers convinced america to eat
fish sticks since they were introduced
in 1953 fish sticks have become an
unlikely staple today americans eat 55
million pounds of them a year and during
the pandemic consumption has been on the
rise around i mean look if you like the
flavor they're a great affordable food
like but the problem is is if you don't
like the flavor you're [ __ ] out of luck
yeah fish sticks because it
they were
frozen
they're fairly sustainable the unlikely
success of fish sticks this is an
article written in this year i mean last
year i mean this fish sticks have been a
topic like an actual topic i'm weirdly
now getting a craving to eat fish sticks
of course you are this is what happens
god oh my god you think fish sticks
should be in a battle versus anything
but neither of us love them but what is
like
but the battle of the low grade like you
know like what is
for what they are what is something in
the fish stick around stick versus
chicken croquette
chicken croquette you mean potato
croquette no chicken chicken croquette
chicken croquettes those are like a
frozen chicken
breaded thing it's like a breaded
that's chicken crochet
so pimp if you're not if you if you
don't know pimp just pulled up a bunch
of crocheted chickens
like actual chickens that would crochet
like stuff like that frozen chicken
balls that you can get and it's like
it's like it's like mostly bread i think
that's a good thing to put against
when you read the ingredient not bad i
mean no i don't know we'll we'll figure
it out but can you make it into maddie
versus fish sticks chicken patty like
the frozen chicken we'll figure it out
put throw throw fish sticks on the
docket and we'll fix it it'll linger
until we figure it out so okay you're
making fun of
a fish fillet what are you saying i'm
saying this is my analogy i come into a
conversation i go the filet of fish
sucks i hate it
ari then goes but mcdonald's is great
and i go i didn't say mcdonald's wasn't
great i said the fellaia fish sucks
yeah but dude like who cares there's the
big mac there's the quarter pounder
there's the
i know
that's not my argument my argument is
the filet of fish at one point he did
say that fellaia he didn't think that
fellaia fish sucked yes
and i said
this is the kind of thing where we have
a conversation about this all the time
for instance last week you came into the
room and said the whopper sucked i
didn't agree but i went along with it
because that's what we do i i don't
remember who the whopper is
i i
i don't remember specifically but like
my point is is like that's the
you know what we're doing here we're
having some fun i'm making fun of
something yeah yeah
and
what is that oh and he you know he went
real he went real like like like literal
on it
like real literal on it
oh lord
are you going to change your good mood
no i'm still in a good mood
but anyway that's that didn't take me
that put me in a bad mood for about an
hour yesterday how do you leave a group
chat
i think you just click on the group that
you believe oh really oh no but you're
still in it though the second someone
chat right there they left no
i don't know i've never that's something
else
i know that's a group you never left a
group chat
i don't i don't think so you just slide
on the name and you can delete yourself
out of it oh really right delete another
person out of it okay
well well you might have to be the host
of the chat to do that i don't know yeah
anyway but it's a good day it's a good
day it's a good day today and today we
are battling roe versus wade
[Laughter]
i'm kidding i don't mean to make light
of a serious thing
we're battling
yeah
no yeah no no that's yeah what
but we wouldn't be battling rovers the
way we'd be rattling roe versus wade
versus i know it's a joke yeah oh no i
guess she would be battling roe versus
wade
although i don't know i liked it i don't
know
it was a dumb joke i don't know the same
i don't know semantics
i know the outcome i forget exactly
you're like the guy in goodfellas when
pesci goes make that coffee to go and
then the guy actually grabs the pot
a piece she goes what the [ __ ] are you
doing because you shouldn't make the
coffee to go because it's a [ __ ] joke
you're like that guy another
is that another analogous
analogous
i know joe i'm making a joke sound i
know
you we are
let's stand the same we're all over the
charts babe all right we're doing
battling we're doing olive garden
italian kitchen
versus i know it's called a tiny kitchen
the olive garden versus outback
steakhouse
oh boy man
waiting to do this one we posted this
weeks ago we posted it and we couldn't
get to it and we both did not look
at the results the results have been out
there for a few for a couple of weeks
and they did a 24-hour cycle so the
results should be in the tens and tens
and tens of thousands of votes
um
there's a lot to cover here and i don't
know where are we now pimp
about 30. all right there's a lot to
cover here babe let's get into this
battle all right without further ado
here we go
by the way sorry i was sick on the last
episode everybody and thank you for
understanding i appreciate it
olive garden you're going to step in the
ring with me
defending the olive garden are you nuts
i'm ready to go bro are you nuts this is
a restaurant
that just about every italian american
has denounced i know as disgraceful
as offensive it's the thing to do ad
campaign has become a joke
and i got to tell you something with
olive garden once you get past that the
the the the um gimmick of bottomless
salad which by the way
after a bowl you've had enough untrue uh
after you get past the gimmick of
bottomless salad you got nowhere to go
at olive garden all right first of all
let's just start a little bit more broad
we're doing italian cuisine versus
australian cuisine well no steaks
steakhouse but it's it's with an
australian theme but it's not australian
cuisine ah but it is right no it's it's
outback's steakhouse what is outback
what steak does outback have in the
steakhouse where where is it why is it
why is it deeming itself australian they
just thought like it was like a rugged
theme for a steakhouse do you know that
let's look i don't have my glasses so
you gotta go big large fonts it's an
american chain of australian themed
casual dining restaurants
serving american cuisine wait let me
start from the beginning let's go this
is gonna be so much fun this episode
outback steakhouse is an american chain
i just said that of australian themed
casual dining restaurants serving
american cuisine that's what i just said
based in tampa florida
i mean that sounds like the worst
sentence to describe a restaurant i've
ever heard i want to see you shane has
over 1 000 locations in
23 countries throughout north north and
south america asia and australia imagine
going into outback in australia
it's an outback steakhouse give me a
break it was founded in march 1988 with
its first location in tampa by bob
basham it was owned and operated in the
united states
three of the other founders well i mean
that we don't need to go all right
scroll back up him a little bit more
they opened in canada oh i just okay it
was acquired by bloomin brands okay
cause all you got at outback steakhouse
you know what you got there right you
got the bloomin onion and then you got
nothing else
listen i don't even i don't even f with
the bloomin on you when i go
kiss my ass pasta can be
pasta
it doesn't there's no there's no crazy
formula to pasta but if you're going to
get a steak a cut of beef a choice prime
usda cut of beef the right way you're
not going to go to outback for a steak
and i got news for you you want to get
pasta the right way with a decent
marinara or a decent piece of meat or
fish with it you're not going to to to
olive garden
here's what i think i think olive garden
is a punch line it's been for a long
time now but i think that
it doesn't even matter i think that even
people who use olive garden as a punch
line once in a while can find themselves
there and they don't even mind it and
i'll tell you another thing once in a
while i think people are like i would go
to the algon i could go for it i think
you get equal versatility in both
restaurants i think you're shortchanging
the outback's menu outback has chicken
it's got steak they've got ribs they've
got seafood they're serving tuna sashimi
now
they've got all kinds of stuff when you
see that
all right yeah all right let's go olive
garden started as a unit of general
mills the first olive garden was up oh
it was open on december 13th 1982 in
orlando it all starts in wow
in orlando by 89 there were 145 olive
garden restaurants make it the fastest
growing uh
general mills restaurant division olive
garden restaurants were uniformly
popular and the chains per store sales
soon matched former sister company red
lobster
the company eventually became the
largest chain of italian-themed
full-service restaurants in the u.s keep
scrolling pimp general mills spun
spun off its restaurant holdings blah
blah
blah
stand-alone company by 90 by 2009 olive
garden was darden's most inexpensive
restaurant chain with an average check
per person of 15
versus 90 at its sibling capital grill
these things are all in the same
conglomerate a former president of olive
garden said that sales in existing
restaurants sharply decreased with a 12
decline occurring at one point even
though the company was quickly
establishing new restaurants all right
give me a little more juice on it you
got you got nothing when it comes to the
locations
advertising and marketing okay first of
all
their original slogan was good times
great salad olive garden you're dead
how's that
is your restaurant when you got to put
salad in the logo that's what you're
selling it's a pot place and they're
pushing salad nah they're pushing stuff
here's the thing first of all whoever
came up with when you hear your family
give that person a raise okay
everybody knows that saying i like the
saying i joke i did you ever one time i
found myself in times square and i don't
know why i don't know why but there's an
i know that's still there there was an
olive garden in times square
that thing by the way you can't
it's harder to get into than rayos
you can't get into the olive garden in
times square so so one time i'm there
and i'm like
i don't know if it was on a lock or we
just really wanted food i don't know
what it was want to go online there the
lady tells me it's a two
two hour wait
to eat it's a it's a three-story
restaurant with about a thousand she
tells me it's a two-hour wait i looked
her right in the face and said this is
the way you treat family
[Laughter]
it's listen but i will tell you the
never-ending pasta bowl
boom bap okay never-ending salad and
breadcrumbs gimmicks you're working can
i tell you i really like the salad and
breadsticks i think they do a really
good job i think they do a really good
job that's fine but you're working all
gimmicks you go into outback it's not a
gimmick that's a statement
anytime you gotta put never-ending and
all you can it's all it's been it's been
never ending salad since day one it's
not a gimmick never ending pasta is a
gimmick never eating salad is a gimmick
it's a gimmick that gets that catches
your eye
it's it's never any pasta was a huge
gimmick they did that started in 2013
according to their wikipedia
i mean dude look at this you honestly
think let's go menu to menu okay
classic so we're in a picture menu right
now of olive garden you tell me how many
of those you actually think look
appetizing if that was shown to you and
you didn't know it was on olive garden's
website you would think those are
classic italian dishes no no don't joe i
want you to be honest joe
i want anything from you
the chicken marsala looks like salisbury
steak
um
scroll back up pimp please
the the
chicken alfredo the chicken and shrimp
carbonara um the fettuccine alfredo
literally look like they have milk
poured on top of them ah come on the
chicken parmesan the chicken parmesan
looks processed look at the exact amount
of sauce on top of the exactly shaped
patties that are identical with the
exact amount of cheese on top oh it's a
menu photo look at the family style
lasagna in the microwave
oven tin thing no that's
that's a nice touch they bring out the
whole tray for you it's in the
disposable freezer aisle thing that you
buy at the store that is not disposable
i guarantee you that's hard i guarantee
you you think that's hard i think it's a
pen you think you're getting hard 10. i
know i'm getting a hard time you're out
of your mind you think they're bringing
out
four that is a disposable
two dollar you buy it and throw it away
stop it stop it all right but stop my
point is i think it's a nice touch stop
it you're what you're doing is you're
buying the whole thing that's a nice
touch if you put that on the center of
your table at a dinner party i'd spit on
your table that's not true that's that's
not true at all at home we make lasagnas
in those tins are you nuts
are you nice you don't serve a lasagna
in a tin like that yes you do you put
that tin right at the bottom
funeral reception
you're wrong you take that tin out of
the oven you drop it right on the table
and you cut squares right out of that
tin
prove me wrong please scroll back wrong
please scroll how do you serve your
lasagna how do you cook and serve your
casserole in a glass casserole babe i
put it in a glass casserole
i oil a glass casserole
but you're acting like that's out of
line look at those not out of the line
my italian family cooks lasagna it's not
bad
if it's a couple of pals getting
together or you and your lady or
whatever cooking for yourselves or maybe
you're making something for the kids to
serve it at olive garden is out of focus
no i think it's a nice touch i think
it's a touch of honey horrible soups
that look like they were poured out of
chunky i think i think that you can run
your mouth all
are you going away this summer did that
did that full hard-boiled egg you just
eat did that come from the hellofresh my
hello freshman in the did you pull an
egg out of my brown bag at one of my
hello fresh meals no i did not but hello
fresh is selling is sending you uh those
types of delicious meals i just had a
wonderful salad with some egg and some
other things and it was great uh and are
you going away this summer was the
question i was gonna ask why because
maybe you want to get into the shape you
want to get into maybe you don't have
time to do the all the cooking and the
whatever blah blah blah blah or maybe
you just want to receive kits where
you're going to
whatever you think your kit thing is
there for you you think that you guys
have a lot of recipes using other kits
hellofresh has 30 recipes more than any
other meal kit plan okay they have
summer recipes like cucumber salads
stuffed pita pockets chicken sausage
stuffed peppers tuscan spice shrimp and
so much more hello fresh is 72 cheaper
than dining at a restaurant it's even
cheaper than grocery shopping the newest
menu releases include mediterranean
recipes filled with fresh fruits veggies
nuts olive oils and fiber packed whole
grains for a nourishing balance
customize your favorite dishes with
hello custom offerings that's new
by swapping out one protein or a side or
something for another protein or side
whatever you want to do you can upgrade
to a more luxe experience or even add
protein or a veggie to a meal that means
more choices more variety more meals
truly tailored for you the point is is
hellofresh is flexible they'll start
sending your kit that you get in one
place to another place if you're there
for the summer whatever you need they
got your back so go to hellofresh.com
tastebuds16 and use codetastebuds16
for up to free
16 meals that's 16 free meals and get
three free gifts again hellofresh.com
tastebuds16 use code tastebuds16 for up
to 16 free meals and three free
gifts america's number one meal kit
you ever been in a pinch for cash
i have been
and everyone hasn't been everyone is all
the time everyone i've never met anyone
there's like no people that are not in a
pinch for cash uh and and by pinch you
know i'm talking you you get hit with
some unexpected expenses sometimes it's
a tax bill sometimes medical bill tax
bill comes out of nowhere gas maybe it's
a medical bill that's another thing
guest prices the way they are now maybe
you're just someone who's trying to fill
up your tank and you're on a budget and
all of a sudden out of nowhere now gas
just doubled in price also
sorry not cool also it did just double
in price it did yeah i know
i know i just said that i know i'm
agreeing with you it's wild i know it's
used to throwing 50 bucks in your car a
week now you've thrown in 100 over the
course of a month that's 200 bucks if
you're on a budget where is that coming
from hindsight is 20 20 you can't change
the pass but what if you could get a
little help from your future self maybe
you'd ask to borrow a little cash now
you can with dave
davis banking app that can help you get
up to 500
instantly with extra cash if you're
living paycheck to paycheck you need a
little room elbow room to breathe a
little buffer whatever dave can help
with some more money to fill your tank
to buy the wedding gift
maybe to plan the wedding to catch up on
bills whatever it is you could find
stuff tackle any of those bills you've
been stressing out i have you hung up a
bit there's no interest and is no credit
check required millions of people have
already downloaded the dave app to get
financial relief they need with extra
cash so if you're in a pension need some
extra help download dave and think of it
as a helping hand from future you you
can finally tackle some of those
expenses that have been stressing you
out without any hang-ups folks again
we've all been there especially with the
last few years we've all been through
download the dave app from the app store
right now that's d-a-v-e
sign up for an extra cash account
sign up for extra cash account say it
again it's good and get up to 500
instantly for terms and conditions go to
dave.com
legal instant transfers instant transfer
fees apply banking provided by evolve
member fdic future you will thank you
guys
if you didn't see this page if i just
showed you these stock photos you would
say these are stock photos of meals oh
you wouldn't be like you wanted to grow
stock photos
let's pull up outback go to the picture
menu of let's go let's go because you're
going to serve yourself the same thing
right here look at that oh that looks
terrible that looked terrible it looks
like he's throwing diarrhea on top of a
steak are you kidding me that's not fair
literally apples to apples
what was that unidentified brown liquid
pouring over the top of that picture i
got news
[Laughter]
it's the same photographer come on 100
to say photographer why does that rib
eye
red stuff on top
and you're telling me those aren't
that's not frozen broccoli you know it
is
you know it is
uh
you can't say [ __ ] i can't defend it i
can't defend it i can't these pictures
are terrible look at that that looks
horrible that looks like they scooped
out of a tv dinner i can't defend it oh
go ahead go to town i went to the town
of yours go to town it's awful i'd
rather eat an outback steak
what is that plate is that a plastic is
that a plastic microwavable plate i'm
gonna say it's an iron uh
like one of those metal black uh iron
things
oh i hate that when they do like the
thing with the sauce in the plates
look dude
did you see that look at the tin look at
the tin they're serving the mac and
cheese out of the same pan they're
serving the lasagna yeah
[Laughter]
i mean yours looks like literally it
looks
this looks like like school cafeteria
food that lobster you know it does that
lobster tail looks good that looks like
something out of a school cafeteria that
lobster tail looks good well presented
the bloom and onion i've never been a fa
look that plate looks like
serve it in a better plate
are you that plate that plate looks like
that like a nondescript like plastic
plate from listen to me i can't i can't
you can't those lobster tails look good
you can't defend this bro you can't
defend that it's literally the same
exact photograph fair enough so let's
move on
but
versatility on the menu
we got steaks we got lobster
he just scrolled by looks like he just
scrolled a page and it was just 60s
aussie cheese fries sydney shrooms
i mean how stupid is this how stupid is
this restaurant they have fries and they
gotta call them aussie fries
they gotta give little little australian
nicknames to regular american food is
this restaurant you're gonna say how
stupid is this versus the the the the uh
i'm back i have a question for you when
you're out at outback answer me this
question when you're at outback are you
family you think i want to be family
with the obvious people i don't see you
as family you had a picnic a family
reunion
friends at outback are they treated you
had a family reunion picnic and the
olive garden showed up that's the family
you said we had to invite them and you'd
hope that they stayed in the corner of
the yard for themselves nobody wants
that family at the at the picnic what is
that look at that caramel mustard glazed
pork chop it looks disgusting
they got bloom and fried chicken it
looks like they literally made a tv
dinner and slid it on fried chicken it's
an atrocity look at that what does all
that what is all that stuff on top of
the chicken unidentified sauces
oh
don't get me wrong i'd go to outback or
go to outback oil i've gotten tonight
and getting chicken tenders look good
i love that you have fallen so far so
fast that you just
to describe your defense to outback you
said the chicken tenders look good
why is that called alice springs chicken
is that because queensland and alex
springs is a location in australia and
they have to keep with the theme what
about so they're naming things like
apple pie aussie apple pie
the burgers look good look french onion
soup that looks good no it doesn't joe
all right pimp take us to the phones
this isn't the phones this is a train
wreck you want to go to the phones this
is a train wreck we're in about 40
minutes i want to see what some people
are saying
oh i mean dude sticking it up now i
here's what i like i feel like you go to
outback there's an whether it's
authentic or not or whether it makes you
feel this way or not i feel like it
makes certain people i feel it's an old
an old world type of theme
and it was inside the core the inside of
the court in an olive garden recently
not too recently it's sad dude it feels
like a denny's they they've gone the way
the dodo they feel like denny's at least
with the outback there's remnants of
their of their aussie uh interior in
there it's an american restaurant
founded in tampa that they threw out
back on because they needed an angle is
more sterile to me than than the olive
garden i agree that looks like that
looks like the old that was like tuscany
that looks like that looks like
everything looks like tuscany no it
looks like every suburban neighborhood
you've ever been in where you can go
we don't know where else to go to eat
and you go into the olive garden i like
going in that you know what i like i
just i don't care i like little nice
touches i like
showing i see effort they're going the
extra way i like to sit down and all of
a sudden without even asking boom salad
and bread sticks are dropped and by the
way we skipped the bread
the bread is nice
do you think outback's not putting a
bread basket down
i don't know about that they're a
hundred percent putting a bread basket
down is halfback putting down a bread
basket
well they're not putting down a bowl of
free salad which by the way the first
the first comment already was golden on
twitter
i don't think so pantry honey wheat buns
at outback a honey wheat bread that was
a recipe that sounds delicious that's
what you're getting you get a loaf it's
a recipe bro no but it's a recipe
you're not getting a pantry honey wheat
bread i don't know about that it's a
recipe for the bread they put down on
the table
it's a cotton i don't know people are
charging for bread these days i don't
know i'm telling you so you get free
bread sticks at olive garden you don't
think you get free bread sure give me
i'll give you the bread you get your
honey bread okay but i got breadsticks
salad for free no no it's not free
salad's not free you got to pay
extra i could go in there with a [ __ ]
20 bill and i can't even
die it's never ending for a price i can
go into olive garden with a jackson and
eat until i die they can't tell me
otherwise i will have salad and pasta
until i die or you can go to outback and
get that
aussie fries and be just as full
now come on please you know you don't
love just the idea around the romance
around something that's never-ending
like a never-ending love listen i love
never ending i love a buffet i love it
all you can eat i've always been pro
that thing this is what i was telling
you when a restaurant
has to do it it's a gimmick it's like
it's like a golden corral it's a gimmick
i will all day i will all day they got
gold corrals the meaning of these
old world mediterranean music at olive
garden
i'm saying i go in there and i'm
immersed in tuscany is how i feel
sometimes listen first comment from rich
when you're here your family [ __ ] that
family give me aussie fries the sauce
monkeys that are olive garden never
sliced the onion thin enough two out of
ten outback all the way olive garden is
an insult to australians all over the
united states it wasn't interesting
that's gotta be a typo i picked olive
garden because the one time i had staked
it out back it was thick tasteless
tasty it was a thick tasteless tough
chunk of meat no [ __ ] their saving grace
is the heart attack special illuminating
your entire your thing is a steakhouse
you wanted to say that i lean on salad
olive garden let me finish
your thing
you're a steakhouse that pushes an onion
ring you your claim to fame is an onion
ring a fried onion
right now and by the way
you got to give me a chance here we're
on the phone olive garden is the red
lobster of italian food as a kid you
think it's fancy when you get older you
realize the microwave is working ot in
the kitchen back there outback days
thousand a1 all day okay stop freeze
freeze
okay this person is an idiot and i'll
tell you why because
he could have gone one more sentence and
said and outback is the same exact thing
he's saying
olive garden is that outback all day
the microwave broken olive garden come
on man dude i'm telling you right what
they are
bloom and onion i'm not a fan of the
blooming onion i'm really not but you
want to talk bloom and onion olive
garden bloom and onion has made it has
has set its mark in the annals of food
history with the big mac the whopper
it's it's there dude it is when you go
name me a classic legendary dish at an
american chain restaurant bloom and
onion is in top 10 dude an order of one
order of bloom and onion is 1700
calories all right i i'm not talking
about if it's healthy for you an outback
original our special onion is hand
carved cooked until golden and ready to
dip into our spicy signature blooms
and onion is is jordan pippin it's it's
it's right there dude outback has
nothing joe nothing on you i want to
take you serious in these i want to you
can't call them an hour of gardening you
just go over
are you telling me in the nvp annals of
american restaurant history the blooming
onion is not in top ten it's no it's not
michael you're nuts you got the balls on
you to call the bloomin on your
microphone then
scotty pippen and it's that i'm just
saying it's in the top
caught right it's mvp team status and
you don't think that never ending salad
and pasta is the [ __ ] out of here no
you're you're crazy you're crazy oh guy
when you hear your family outback
stegosaurus when you're here you're a
middle-aged divorcee burying your
feelings in a blooming onion true
olive garden is basically italian
mcdonald's pimp hold on scroll back
italian mcdonald's but i'm a [ __ ] for
never-ending bread
you go no joke i love olive garden
breadsticks so much if i had a whole
basket i crammed them in all my holes
and orifices until i look like a ged
blowfish
outside with i'll slide three
breadsticks down my gullet before i go
to a restaurant that has a sign that
says aussie rules even though it's an
overpriced dump off the expressway that
they mean olive garden olive garden wins
off their mozzarella sticks alone
olive garden along the side hold on a
second if you've ever had mozzarella
sticks in a decent
please dude please monster all sticks
could be good at the olive garden no
they're not
them they're not good garden alongside
good breadstick i had a decent meal
where they listened to what i ordered
the one time i went okay what percentage
of olive garden menu is prepared in the
microwave
all of this all of it
anyone from texas will vote olive garden
because no one here touches outback
where there's a texas roadhouse ever
that's a terrible argument i agree
unlimited soups i didn't even know about
the soup and they're not even talking
about pasta unlimited soup salad and
breadsticks you want a deal do you want
a deal
do you want to you want to spend ten
dollars on an onion for 1700 calories or
do you want to walk in there and do you
want to deal do you want to eat until
you're good and ready
i ask you
and olive garden you can go there and
you can eat as much as you want they'll
keep bringing it your only argument is
is that you can go into this place and
eat like an endless pig
civilized person and say i'm spending
this amount of money on food i'm gonna
have a meal that has limits i'm sorry if
my meals have limits
i don't know what you're talking about
i'm talking about a never-ending salad i
really like the way they prepare it i'll
tell you another thing i don't think
oliver i'll be straight i don't think
olive garden
makes everything the best but i do think
that there are items on the olive garden
menu that are completely passable if not
okay
this might be our winner
i've never been to either my family had
class
let's give him the win
follow at ice pack jack that's very
funny and give him a retweet pimp if
it's not too late i know this is an old
olive garden's going to be carried by
the midwest vote i took my prom date to
red lobster 20 years ago because olive
garden was booked solid and if you were
real late to book as a as a res to book
a reservation you were eating good at
the neighborhood at applebee's all the
horse kids were at bob evans
okay uh i already voted on this so i
can't scroll up without showing you the
result all right take us to the results
we're about there 22 000 votes 22 000
votes okay
all right wait wait drum roll this
please
it's humble pie segment
um yes
yes
yes oh my god you got to be kidding me
yes no
the number's gone i really thought i was
going to beat you
53.4 olive
i think we go and loses with 46.6
to 53.4 outback steakhouse wins
honestly i think that's close enough to
go again three percentage points well i
am shocked at you guys it's not five
percent
it's it's three and a half percent what
are you talking about that's you've got
six there's a differential of six and
change there no it's a 50.
no 47 to 50 is three 50 to 53 is three
that's six points right i'm just saying
not counting the extra i'm just saying
you have three percent
more people
i won by six percent right
so no there is no rematch
the [ __ ] are you talking about you took
my three percent and you put them on
your side
i i don't know what you're doing right
now
you have to be within five percent of a
win to the devil
yes
i think it's close
it's not it's not because that's how
rules work
what is the rules you want to talk rules
you lost the first season and you have
yet to do anything about it come up with
a punishment there has been 10
punishments
[ __ ] i'm right here punish me all right
fine i'm opening it up right now
this is it this is it and we're doing it
and i'm but here's the thing i'm not
just taking any uh uh no well punishment
that comes down the point we'll vote
we'll keep it in taste buddy's team will
vote here's the thing slop it off at 52.
whatever the record was at 52 i'm pretty
sure he lost the second season is 53 to
104 okay so that's where the new one is
guys whoever does the great analogies
out there analogous
give us a record at the end of 52 and
from 52 to present then what i want in
the comments guys right now
and have fun all you want but i want you
to suggest what could be a punishment
for joe anything you want suggested it
will pluck but hold on
hold on there's some rules here i'm not
doing anything that's going to hurt me
you don't have to do listen to me let me
finish all right suggest away taste
buddies log on to youtube suggest away
or write to pimp at
just
the taste buds twitter tweet at the
tastebuds twitter
we will call all of these things and we
will pick four things that we think are
good and then we will put them up to a
vote to the fans you'll have to approve
the four okay you approve the four and
then we will let you guys decide what
his fate is because i have had enough of
his talking out of his ass that he has
to get punished for losing what he's
talking about we've had a hard rule the
whole time that if it's under five
percent in the margin you do it i'm just
saying you have not had you come up for
losing the first year you like to just
push and push with the rules you go well
i think six is close enough now no it's
not close enough five point five is not
close enough i think
i think olive garden takes out back on a
rematch i do
that's nice
i'm based on my
my feet my my feeling my instinct your
ego your ego oh that's what it is i love
gardening
i still love you babe the episode's off
i love you too
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right taste buds man
yeah they're coming to the mic i'm
talking taste buds